hi i'm stephanie hi i'm diane and we
play sisters in the new disney film
encanto coming to theaters this november
24th we are very excited to share this
film with you today we're going to be
making
queso
we're going to be competing to see whose
are better they're going to be mine to
be judged by
we clearly wore the right sleeves for
this yep yeah we did so oh you put the
water in first i'm just
okay what feels natural and instinctual
to
and since i am colombian and you are too
these are going to be great because it's
in our blood that's right i remember my
mother i think doing this with her hands
just her bare hand yeah the whole
process just for bear
my mom didn't wear these sleeves
my dad makes these almost every
christmas and they're
delicious you know and they're only like
four inches around right so you feel
like oh well i've only had one at epa
and then by the time you're done you've
become an edible
okay this is looking really good wow
this is great i mean this is very
simple ingredients right this is
cornmeal salt water well in the film
almost every character has magical
powers right you've got a magical power
my character doesn't um it's fine it's
really fine it's fine it's not a big
deal it's fine
um and my mom in the film our mother her
magical power is healing people through
the power of food which i think is such
a beautiful metaphor because so many
people have memories around food
traditions around food
i am starting to sweat a little bit okay
so the next step is you take out your
masa
so you put it on your counter you shape
it into a eight-inch log this is where
your hands come in right now you're
measuring i brought my own ruler wait
till my parents see me making arepas
with a ruler we've come a long way you
guys so you make it with like a log now
do i cut it with the um
okay
you know i called my mother before
before i came on this show what'd she
say she said that my dad would make them
she said my dad would make them and they
would make a bunch um in the beginning
of the week and then at the end of the
week on the weekend right they would get
all the leftovers from the week so like
beans and rice and chicharron and
chorizo whatever what have you and it
would make a big talent right and then
they would have it with a little area oh
that sounds so nice
okay so now diane's beating me sorry
okay we'll we'll go find no we'll go
together it's a competition but like so
just go ahead all right you know when
i'm just gonna make all my bolitas and
then we go to the next step this is my
first time making it by the way is it
really yeah is it yours
no
we put like a hefty tablespoon of cheese
in there right like personally i would
probably put this entire thing of cheese
in here if i could fit it in but i can't
right here boom oh no no pretty good oh
my gosh
oh dear
you're doing great thanks it's good to
um encourage other people when they're
cooking
dishes for the first time you don't want
people to get in their heads and not be
able to make things because they see
somebody else doing really well wait so
you so you do this
okay
yeah like that i feel like i almost
should have mushed this arepa mix a
little better it looks good yeah yeah
but i'm just wondering what it would
have
wow you're frying yours already okay
here we go it's fine it's not it's
because i waited for you i'm not waiting
for you anymore
i'm just gonna go ahead you can pan fry
you can deep fry i guess if you really
want to go for it there's also like
those air fryers air frying and irepa is
the most gen z possible thing
ever it's very juicy it's i remembered a
lot of this but it's not working for me
it's like that like this and then like
patting it like you pat it like you pat
like a little baby's butt
yeah little baby little baby butt baby
butt and then you fry them roughly three
and a half four minutes on each side oh
my god i forgot this part
oh can i say that sorry we're also
making toppings for these now i'm going
to make an avocado mash and i'm going to
make a kale chorizo
my parents would be like yes girl guess
cute yes
what do you think the key to a good
arapah is ammo
i'm sorry
i'm laughing because i was gonna say
castle like well you're right yeah i
think that anything made with love is
like gonna be better and it's such an
easy dish and it's also not expensive
right none of this is expensive like
anybody can make it in a pinch you can
have it with anything you can have it
with something salty you can have it
something sweet like you can make
chocolate chocolatico with this
you dip this in the chocolate oh my
goodness so freaking good they're not
expensive to make so when there is a gen
z added up a restaurant that opens and
they're charging twelve dollars per hour
don't do it don't buy them wow mine are
gonna be a little on the greasy side
let's keep going and do our toppings so
now we're making our toppings mine is an
avocado mash avocado cilantro crushed
red pepper lime and then salt so oil
first of course because we're going to
have to saute our stuff i'm just going
to start garlic you need garlic don't
want to touch it because then your hands
smell like garlic all day wow that
smells good immediately yeah i know i
was worried that my deodorant was going
to make this shirt smell funky and no no
that's going to be the garlic
they're going to have to give me this
shirt now this looks like something i
would eat do you like cooking do you
like cooking kale in in like this and
like like this i like this i like a kale
saute like a kale saute and a little
olive oil maybe a little ghee what's
ghee you don't know what ghee is no oh
my god ghee is clarified butter it's oh
so good okay clarified butter really
delicious i like a little bit of avocado
chunk in the mash you know what i mean
like i don't like guacamole when you get
it and it's like
thin baby food i love chorizo
i eat way too much chorizo though
but i love it possibly there's not
enough chorizo in the world when you
taste your food do you taste it and like
keep mixing it with the same spoon you
know what i don't taste my food it's a
surprise for everyone
i feel like you might win based on the
topping which i'm not sure is fair but
i'm gonna let you have it no but i think
with arepas it's the arepa
see what vanessa thinks adding the rest
what else oh that's right you have more
parts i got should i just stand here and
eat my chocolate yeah just eat your
topping this is salt apple cider vinegar
whoa here we go and
a little
honey
this is what's going to make it sweet
obviously because this is a sweet kale
chorizo that's good that's awesome and i
love the little shaved garlic
like that yeah did you do that did you
cut your garlic yeah i learned it like
paper personally yeah it's really good
but the with the italian
the italians taught me
real with a nice little razor sharp
thing shout out to good fellas oh
ray liotta what up i feel like we're
ready we're ready let's plate
they came out so cute
awesome i'm really proud of myself i
feel like our families would be proud of
us oh absolutely right yeah my dad can't
believe it can't believe it hey yeah
that's uh pretty good that looks uh
pretty good your parents do that oh yeah
yeah mine too that's where my sense of
like wanting to be perfect comes from
very much like your character very much
like my character yeah yeah wow ready
for judging
[Music]
vanessa come in here before diane
replates hurry up was it supposed to be
played with your eyes based on how they
look alone i'm not gonna lie i would
house that entire plate that looks
absolutely delicious to me i would eat
this first and then i would move on to
my main dish you know what i mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah i could see that i mean
if we were at an arepa restaurant and
both of these came to the table i would
not be mad at either one no me neither
hello
how are you guys
i'm very excited so am i i haven't had
breakfast all right they both look good
okay this one looks really fancy
come on you know this
i'm just gonna go for it
[Music]
oh i like the cheese okay guacamole
so what is this it's sweet kale and
chorizo
[Music]
that looks so good i'm not gonna lie it
looks so good so first impressions i
love the fanciness of this one
but this flavor is like really intense
and i like i love that it's so different
my favorite one
has to be this one
it's just like i don't know it feels
more like
those
are bombs can i go for it yeah
you need them you guys killed that thank
girl we are excited for you guys to see
arapascal on the big screen
in encanto this november 24th we're so
so excited to share our movie and our
culture with you we can't wait hope you
love it
oh yes
[Music]
you